before I met my wife I never cracked $3
million per year and after I met my wife
24 months later I took home over 17
million in personal income and there are
17 lessons that she taught me so the
first one I learned from her was never
stifle a generous impulse whether it's a
gift or praise as soon as you think it
send it and so when I started you know
my businesses earlier on I obviously you
know I got up to about 30 employees
between my gyms honestly I was not that
good at running it and it was because I
just ran everything off of fear and
Punishment and it sounds more malicious
than it probably was that's just kind of
how like most small business owners
operate is they just kind of like yell
at people when they mess up and if I'm
not talking to you it means you're doing
everything fine which is kind of like
the opposite of how you want to run a
business because then that means that
you just condition everyone to fear
talking to you because it means when you
talk to them you only there to punish
them and so then your employees start
avoiding you and they don't tell you
what's going on in the business and so
when Lila came in she had come from uh
had two really positive working
environments that worked out before and
one really negative one and she had seen
the big contrast the thing that really
motivated her and just transparently has
been one of the secret star of success
is that she's always wanted to have an
amazing place to work as in create and
Foster an environment where people feel
safe and comfortable and praised for the
work they do and the smart thing about
that is that you have kind of two levels
of effort that you can unlock in every
person so the first level which is what
most people work at which is the minimum
amount to not get punished and so if you
punish someone if they do anything below
this then they just go right above that
so they basically do the law of least
effort so they just go right above that
just enough to not get punished and
that's how most people live their lives
it's also really unfulfilling kind of
sucks and people don't live to their
potential and your business doesn't grow
nearly as much as it could the second
level is a completely different fuel
that unlocks something that we call a
discretionary effort which is all of the
effort between what someone needs to do
just to keep their job and as much as
they possibly could if they did their
best all of that upside is discretionary
effort because you wouldn't fire them
even at the bottom but everything else
on on top of that is kind of like gravy
and so she has been so good at unlocking
discretionary effort in all of our
teammates because she really genuinely
Fosters people and coaches them and has
very fast feedback loops we run
everything on a project management tool
and so she's in there all day long just
being like awesome job this is great
keep completing that this is awesome
work hey can you ask me here and she's
just all day long so people are getting
really fast feedback loops from her
constantly for little iterations of work
and so people want to do more things
faster CU they get more feedback faster
from so that's number one on the other
level from a grander level every single
employee comes in fills out a form and
we learn the things they like they don't
like favorite foods that kind of stuff
and when someone does something great
she will immediately find their employee
profile remember the thing that uh they
said they really liked and then usually
send a gift that's related whether it's
a gift card or an animal or a jersey or
whatever the thing is that they kind of
like and it shows people that you really
listen and that you care and the best
way to make people think that you care
about them is to actually care about
them um and Lila does it better than
just about anyone and so I would say
that is the one of the biggest reasons
that we were able to unlock much more
operationally complex businesses is
because people wanted to work I would
say for us but realistically for her um
and they felt they were be invested in
and so they were willing to invest back
to the business the second one is that
you never regret taking a night to sleep
on an emotional response but you do
regret the ones done in the moment and
so when I think back to before Lila I
would often have bad news or something
bad that would happen and I almost like
got off on being angry like being
enraged feels good like it feels like
you're just like in absolute power mode
but then like afterwards you have like
an anger hangover and I definitely did
that a lot in my earlier career and I'd
regret it and then you basically Foster
an abusive relationship and I don't I
use that lightly but more so just that
there's a cycle of anger and then
apology and then anger and apology and
it's just a it's a it's not good for
either party and so what she got me to
do was basically slow down she's like
hey I get you're upset if you're still
upset tomorrow chew their head off and
nine times out of 10 I'd wake up the
next day and be like it's fine they
didn't mean it it wasn't malicious
intent it was just dumb and whatever and
then we asked the question how can we
decrease the likely this happens again
in the future and then we can be
productive about it rather than just
insulting or assassinating someone's
character and she honestly is almost a
freak at this point of being able to
like sit in the middle of like
uncomfortable conversations and have
Zero Effect it's been amazing for our
marriage uh because like I can escalate
um in terms of getting angry and more
aggressive and despite being a girl
who's smaller than me so I don't care
what you say if you're a bigger guy and
there's a girl and you're alone and you
get angry they get scared I don't care
what they say it just like it's a it's a
physical Instinct and she has been able
to tame that in her mind and even when I
can get like more heated she'll just say
like I totally understand where you're
coming from like let's talk through it
let's figure it out and um even just
seeing her do that has helped me learn
to just like regulate my own emotional
responses to stimul a lot better number
three stress doesn't mean there's
anything wrong it means you're alive and
so one of the things Ila jokes about is
like dead people problems it's like if
we want to not have stress about some
she's like ah those are dead people
problems like if if we have zero stress
it means we're dead right and so um the
converse of that or the inverse of that
is that if we feel stress it means we're
doing things and it means that we care
and so I think that reframing anxiety as
just care Ing and there being nothing
wrong with that um has basically stopped
the second line of dialogue of self
judgment around being stressed around
stuff and more times than not I used to
get more stressed about my stress than I
was getting stressed about the thing I
was getting stressed about and so the
amount of stressors that come up in
business every single day are countless
and wherever you put your attention
everything else flows and so being able
to remove the Judgment around caring as
I now see it
um basically released me from all of
that wasted attention and so the amount
of productivity that increased as a
result of not judging myself on those
things was huge the way that she saw
stress and stuff just helped me just be
even more chill and all of these kind of
lad her up to making better decisions
and you know if you think back to the
problems that you had 10 years ago
whatever they are you probably laugh at
the size of the problems you had then
compared to now and I try and forward
cast that to 10 years from now I will
laugh at the problems that have today
and so like as we get bigger we expand
and
so hoping or wishing that we don't have
problems is wishing that we don't win
because if you really want to have no
problems then it means you're wishing
that you fail number four you can feel
bad and do nothing about it man this is
like if Lila has a [__] Jedi power
it's this is that she can sit in
discomfort for a very long time and said
she's like oh I feel terrible about this
and then most people are like what are
you going to do about it and she's like
oh nothing yeah nothing I'm just going
to feel terrible and that's okay and
just the acceptance of like the fact
that I feel terrible is an emotion which
has nothing to do with the actions that
I'm choosing to take because every
action that I would take as a result of
feeling this discomfort is only going to
lead me further away from my goal or
cause me to act in a way that's not
conducive to what I want and often times
when we go to New Growth levels there is
discomfort that's why it's called
Growing Pains not growing gains right
it's painful to grow because you have
change you have stretch marks it's
literally what you have when you grow
and so the discomfort is a requisite for
growth and so to try and then do
something about
it expends effort where none is needed
and it actually detracts from the growth
you actually grow more slowly by trying
to combat your discomfort rather than
accepting it for what it is as a
requisite for the success that you want
to have number five and this one's big
longterm over everything I know what
we're going to do by the time we're dead
and it isn't worth trading that for
anything today that could take away from
it
and like Leila breathes this like she is
so long-term thinking like I really have
learned I would say Almost 100% of my
long-term thinking from her um because
she is just so unwilling to sacrifice
anything in the short term that will
take away from the long-term goals that
we have and I tend to be like and I
think that's a little bit of our yin and
yang and so I tend to move faster I tend
to break things I tend to be more okay
with imperfect like MVP you know menim
of viable product like let's get it out
there and just see what the market wants
things like that and on the flip side
she's so protective of our reputation of
making sure that customer have an
exceptional experience in whatever we do
but I think we've learned of one another
in that way but if you're somebody who's
more like me and if you watch my content
maybe you do resonate more with that um
if you don't have Aila then maybe taking
some of these lessons that I have
learned might help you the same way they
help me which is like you might want to
take an extra second and make sure it
really does what you say it does because
the one thing that can guarantee that
you don't get to where you want to go is
that people think you're a liar and a
liar has a very strong connotation but a
a lot of marketing from a lot of people
is exaggeration to the point of like it
not being true number six the quality of
your business is directly proportional
to the quality of the people you hire
which is directly proportional to your
character and your ability to cast a
Clear Vision and how they fit in it not
just how you accomplish your own goals
and so I would say early Alex was very
much like they're like What's the
mission of the business and I was like
to make lots of money that was the
mission of the business make Alex Rich
um even if that is your mission don't
say that and so she was like no one
wants to work for that she and she would
look at me she be like I don't want to
work for that and I'd be like [__] fine
and so as I've tried to work on myself
and very transparently since Lila joined
me Lila has exceptional character and
honestly the internet will never know
because only the people who work in our
company can really know how great of a
human being she is um but and
unfortunately no one will believe me cuz
I'm her husband and people think that
I'm fluffing her so whatever but you can
judge the validity of that statement
based on the quality of the people that
we bring in because really wonderful
people wouldn't work for people who
sucked and Lea is exceptional and so
because of that I've been able to have
people who work in my companies who are
way above what I could probably attract
to my own and it's all been because of
um honestly her Relentless Drive in
personal development like she actually
has done more personal development work
than I think like than anyone I know um
and just continually trying to get
better I mean one of the the reasons
that I married Lila early on I said and
I told her this it's was like in a word
I was like you're just coachable like
she takes feedback like she actually
only requires one piece of feedback to
make a permanent change it's I haven't
seen anyone like that in my life like
I'll give you an example like when I um
in the very beginning of our
relationship like she would like she
would laugh at like a joke or something
and she'd be like ah you're stupid like
she'd say like that joke and um I think
she did a couple times and I was just
like hey uh probably my own thing I was
like but I don't like when you say that
from that day she's never said it again
the thing is is like the world's a lot
smaller than people think it is
especially the higher up you go and
especially the more talented people you
get because like winners hang around
winners and so it's funny cuz like all
the guys on my media team who were like
the high up dudes know the guys who were
on high up media teams at all other
places and they all talk and I know
who's an
[__] and is a dick to their team and
guess what happens when that guy is
dissatisfied for a day he comes to my
team because hopefully our guys are like
these guys are cool like like we work
hard but we work hard cuz we want to we
want to do a good job and so that that
culture has been because of the
Relentless effort Ila has done to work
on herself so that she can translate
that into her team which then translates
that outwards because if you think about
building an asset which is what a
business is or what it should become if
you want to create something of value
it's never about how much you can do
it's about how much you can organize
everyone in a singular Direction which
is why I said cast a Clear Vision
because sure like on one level if you're
a great person great great then you can
attract great people but great people
will still only be there because there's
an ambition component which is okay
you're cool got it that's checkbox one
check boox 2 I have a dream for my life
does my dream fit within yours and so
you have to cast a vision big enough
that someone else's dream can fit inside
of it I genuinely think that Lela sees
organization as a vehicle for personal
development for everyone in the company
and the fact that we do business I
really genuinely think for her is
secondary so there's an exceptional book
on this by Patrick wiy called the motive
and she asked me to read it for like 2
years and I just didn't because I'm a
wonderful husband um and so one day and
it's like it's like a 100 pages I read
it in 90 minutes before she woke up one
day like I literally sat down it was
like sitting on the counter I was like
ah [__] I'll read it and I I just I read
it cover to cover in one sitting and she
came in to like have coffee with me in
the morning and I just looked at her I
was like I get it I'm really sorry and
if like I highly recommend if you're a
small business owner or you're an
operator you're somebody who actually
runs your business read the motive
um it I was the the bad guy in the
example
and it shows what it looks like to be a
good operator of a business and it was
literally the exact opposite of
everything I did number seven be fast to
extend trust and be even faster to take
it back and so I tend to be the more
trusting of the two of us remember I'm
the Yes man you know someone's like I'll
do XYZ I'm like sure he said he'd do it
why wouldn't he do it she's like did you
not see the flashing scam sign over his
head that just Vegas lighting to being
like I'm a scam and I was like oh [__]
no I didn't see that and so the amount
of um mistakes one that she's helped me
avoid but secondly that Lila will still
extend trust and she does that and I
would say that this particular kind of
quoter ism is more about the team so I
was really fast to extend trust
externally to vendors and Partnerships
and things like that but really slow to
extend internally and I think she is
that flipped is that she's really slow
to extend trust to people outside but
the inside if she's like okay if you
passed all these walls you're in now
like you're in like you're on the team
and we will treat you like you are on
the team but if you give us reason to
not trust you we will take that back and
so that is how I think she's kind of
like protected the kingdom if you want
to say it that way um that I've learned
a lot from her and so I think it's the
internal external kind of dichotomy that
was flipped between the two of us um and
I think because she extend trust um
people trust us back and that was
something like in my organizations that
was just run by me earlier I didn't
trust anyone and no one trusted me
number eight don't require three strikes
to get someone out of your life if
someone shows you their colors believe
them the first time this one I think
Lea's [__] queen of I tend to give
Second Chances again this is more
externally Partners this guy did this
thing in the past you know maybe he was
indicted for fraud it was a
misunderstanding Leela's been just very
adamant that like if someone has a
history of something I don't want to be
their come up story like let someone
else take that shot I'll I'll I'll be
after that because there's a enough
people who have just crushed it and been
awesome the whole time and haven't
[__] anyone over let's just work with
them and um we have avoided a lot of
Calamity because the amount of times
that I have done that and been burned um
is honestly the majority of the time as
as ugly as that sounds and I I I want to
believe in Redemption and I I do I think
but I think I want to believe in it in
some on someone else's D number nine
punishment only get short-term obedience
praise gets long-term loyalty this is
really interesting that took me a long
time to figure out so from a human
behavior perspective um punishment Fades
over time and so let me give you an
example so if if you ever like drank too
much one weekend you wake up the next
day and you're like hung over you're
like I'm never going to drink again and
then the next weekend you're out there
partying what happened is the punishment
associated with The Hangover faded but
the reward associated with getting drunk
and partying stays the same it's the
same reason if you break up with
somebody months later you think about
the good times but you forget about the
bad times you ever see them again then
all of a sudden it all comes rushing
back you're like oh my God this person
sucks what was I thinking right you
remember it all because punishment Fades
reward stays over time and I'm going to
get really
real I think the reason that people
speak really nicely about people who've
been dead for a long time is that that
person has never had the ability to
punish them anymore for a very long time
and they only remember the good
things all that to
say in an organization you can
absolutely get someone to do whatever
you want want if you punish them like if
I hold a gun to somebody's head that's a
threat of punishment you can get them to
adhere for the most part but the moment
you remove the punishment you remove the
threat they behave exactly the way they
were going to before but if you reward
they will always want to have that
reward and it does not fade and so if
you want the team to continue to act the
same way when you are not
there then using reward rather than
punishment is a better long-term
strategy the problem is and this is what
confounds everything is that you can get
way faster results with punishment and
so you have to be more patient and more
willing to continue to invest in people
when they mess up not get angry and
continue to only reward the good things
so that you Orient their behavior in
that way but then you have a longer
on-ramp but then they are way more
self-sufficient long term so you get
higher Returns on an employee by
investing longer in the short term so
you get better long-term rewards whereas
punishment you can change their behavior
quickly but you always have to keep
punishment and you also have to increase
your punishment so if you're the type of
Boss who just always yells the same way
eventually people get immune to it and
so you actually have to increase the
intensity and variety of punishment in
order to keep it effective just getting
into Behavior stuff um and that sounds
like a terrible way to live and so from
her I have seen her just use reward she
just dos out reward in such a strategic
like she's like a uh she's Surgical and
how she can pinpoint how to give reward
at the right time for the right people
for the right activities and Orient the
organization so quickly towards the
cookies or nuggets that she puts out
that everyone just gets excited and she
does it to me too because hey I likes
being rared too and so the thing about
human behavior is that even if you
understand it it still works I'll give
you a really micro example so we had uh
someone on our team who we always really
enjoyed filming with and we wanted to uh
put that person in Char of the whole
department and we're like okay well how
do we get someone else to be just as
good at filming with us and so we were
like okay well can't just tell people
like be good at filming we like what is
it about that person that makes them so
good to film with and what we realized
when we broke it down one of the things
is that like when we were talking they
would not along like they were listening
to what we were saying and so for you
you're just a camera right now but
you're watching this as a person but for
me I'm just looking at a camera and so
having someone behind who's like giving
me feedback in real time created a short
reinforcement or reward Loop that made
it more enjoyable to film with and so
for us identifying that little Loop made
the whole thing more enjoyable and so in
all aspects of business there are these
little short reward Loops that we can
identify and then get really tactical
good about them and incentivize those
things and now when we bring someone in
they know that there's three four five
six activities that somebody who behind
a camera has to do that makes them
excellent behind a camera and then we
can onramp people and reward them for
those activities because those
activities reward the person who's doing
the recording and then that becomes The
Virtuous cycle of reward and that
becomes really fun and profitable 10
then you cannot ask anyone for things
you don't already give them think
patience trust forgiveness so I said
earlier that Lila extends trust first
she extends forgiveness first she is
patient with others first and so I I
would say earlier on in my career
probably still a little bit now I demand
things from people that I might not have
given them or demonstrated first and so
over time I've learned through her
demonstration I've learned from her that
she just demonstrates whatever she wants
and
as more people like to Model Behavior
it's how humans
learn if she does something then people
will do it too and so kind of like the
monkey see monkey do thing I learned
that talk is really cheap from her and
what your actions do through
demonstration speaks volumes and she can
change the entire behavior of a team by
just acting the way she acts and then
people act in accordance with that 11 be
fiercely competitive with yourself
ignore everyone else I spent way too
much of my earlier years in business
before Lila looking at what my
competition was doing I would obsess
over their ads over what they were
saying over what they were producing
over what their workouts work remember
that I was in
Fitness and I was like they're sending
people over to steal my workout I swear
to God I was like I would like worry
that they were stealing my workouts just
crazy stuff and you know what some of
them were but like who cares like if
they're stealing your workouts it means
you're doing better than them it means
they're trying to copy you and Lila was
just so good like Lila is Fier
competitive only against herself and it
like truly is like she actually doesn't
give a [__] about what anyone else is
doing and I uh definitely was really
competitive with other people and then
in so doing just wanted to do better
because I wanted to beat them rather
than because I wanted to get better as
long as I was better than them I felt
like I won and she basically helped me
see she was like I think you have a lot
more potential than beating these people
she's like I think beating these people
is a small goal and so it only put the
bar above my nearest competitor rather
than than what she believed I was
capable of and I think that when you
have somebody who believes in you like
that you start to believe in them too
number 12 listen to feedback the first
time whether it's from friends family
customers employee if it makes you
better change it now no matter how bad
it hurts I definitely had the uh kind of
a little bit of a CEO bubble um before
Ila and I uh started working together
and so people never wanted to give me
bad news because I would chew them out
and so they stopped giving me bad news
but it also meant that they stopped
giving me the truth and so it becomes
very difficult to win if you don't have
the truth and so you make decisions
based on data and the quality of your
decisions based on the quality of the
data and so you cannot say that you want
to make the best decisions and also not
be willing to listen and I definitely
suffered that for a very long time
because most times if you are presented
with the data you can make really good
Solutions like you I used to joke about
this with our team I was like really
good data makes you look like a genius
because if the problems are obvious in
the numbers you can just solve them
where you get into trouble is is where
you don't have the data and you're
basically operating blind and a lot of
people operate like that for years
because their teams don't want to tell
them anything and so Leila one solicits
feedback two she encourages it and I
would say she encourages it even more if
it's negative and so and I'll be really
real with you in the
beginning they will say something mean
because you will solicit the feedback
and then you will have some sort of
facial expression and then you still
like you just have to power through it
and be like please do it again I'm like
I'm on this and I'll give you the magic
question that she's asked that I think
is one of my favorite questions for
feedback which is what would you tell me
if you knew I wouldn't get angry like
what would you tell me if you knew it
wouldn't upset me and it just opens up
the form of like cuz it gives people the
frame because a lot of things people
would tell you if they didn't think it
would upset you and so you say what
would you tell me if you didn't think it
would upset me and you get so much
truthful feedback from people like hey
you're really short or hey you're double
to communicate with or hey you take
really long to respond or hey you tend
to be late on meetings and it really
pisses everyone off like those are
things that people say but if you don't
solicit it that way and so I would
encourage you even maybe even with your
spouse to start but your team it's a
really good exercise uh and you get some
really good answers and a lot of times
you get blind spots that you become made
aware of and at least as far as I'm
concerned like I would rather people
talk [__] to my face 13 this one's a
meaty one all right so I'm just going to
read this directly the best operators
take action immediately on tasks they
don't let anything sit on their desk
they are delegation and accountability
machines not quote systems people they
get mounts of work done through leading
others to think for themselves only dumb
people need rules all right let's break
this down a lot of earlier on business
owners want to sop standard operating
procedure every single component of a
business the problem with that is that
the business environment changes rapidly
and by the time you have sopd everything
everything has changed and so anything
can be continually broken down into
smaller and smaller scills if I said hey
I need you to write a marketing campaign
that is different and can be broken all
the way down to turn on a computer
navigate to Safari go to this URL here
is how you type right like everything
can get broken down but at a certain
point you expect a certain level of
confidence and the way to move quickly
within an organization is to extend
trust and have people who you trust to
make decisions on your behalf in order
for them to make decisions on your
behalf which means that they can move
quickly without having to standardize
every single operating procedure is that
they have shared values with you you say
this is how we want things to be done
and then you demonstrate those things
being done so they know that you are not
full of [__] if people see you say this
is what we do and then in the hard
circumstances you act in accordance with
those values and then you public reward
the people who in hard circumstances
also act in accordance with those values
independent of your intervention of you
interfering more people will do it like
this one is is so prevalent so everybody
who's under 10 million listen up true
operators are leaders like it really
took me a long time to figure this out
it's not about systems like they like
processes they just wave their hands and
really what it means is they just like
make everyone's life harder in order for
a process to be put in place and stay
within an organization it has to make a
net benefit on the organization so
there's something called local cost and
Global cost or local benefits and Global
benefits so I'll give you a simple
example if I ask the sales team to write
notes in the CRM it will have a local
cost they will now have more work to do
than they did before if those notes then
get used by customer support and
onboarding and product and delivery and
they're really integral to the rest of
their client experience there is going
to be a global benefit so more people
benefit the organization will benefit
from this small cost that's a good
return on investment often times quote
systems people don't think that way they
just think everything has to be
somewhere and we have to put systems
around everything and that often times
slows people down and they cannot
communicate what the global benefit is
because if I don't use some of that
information for example then maybe I
shouldn't ask my sales guys to write
that down because all I'm doing is
incurring a local cost but I don't have
a clear benefit and I'll give you a
different example because I think this
is such a prevalent issue in businesses
I had an accounting team in one of our
companies who said hey can we have some
software developers write some code to
automate this task that we do and I was
like okay well how many hours a does it
take they're like takes us like 4 hours
of manual input every week I was like
wow that's tough and so I went to
software developers and I said hey you
know what would it take to do this
they're like oh we can do it in 14 days
and I was like okay accounting team was
like great can you sign off on this I
was like okay hold up what is the cost
of 14 days of a full Dev team doing this
it's 5,000 a day FYI for this particular
team and so 14 days times $5,000 70
grand you work for 4 hours a week on
this thing so it's 52 Time 4 all right
so it's 200 hours now you make $70,000 a
year so 10% of your paycheck gets
allocated towards this task so $7,000 so
in order for me to get a return on this
14-day quick automation system it would
take me 10
years and that's a pretty shitty return
and that assumes that nothing changes
over the next 10 years in our business
that would cause us to have to update
this thing break fix because we switch
systems and I think you can get where
I'm going with this of course it made no
sense but quote system people will
systematize without considering the
long-term consequences and the global
benefits of why they're even doing it to
begin with they just get OCD about [__]
and they just want to system everything
but all they do is slow people down but
Lea has operated every business we've
ever done and the reason they've gotten
big is because she delegates Authority
as soon as things come on her desk she
shoots them out she's just a delegation
machine and she trusts the people and so
it's much more about empowering those
people so that they can do the things
the way they want them to be done as
long as they still meet the objective
and she gives way more Liberty because
she chooses to hire more competent
people which ladds up to some of the
things earlier which is if you have
really dumb people you have to make
really strict rules and if you're
already making strict rules you lost
people will care about you and care
about your business if you act like you
care about them and the easiest way to
act like you care about them is to
actually care about them and so I um I
would say prior to Lila I tend to be
much more like a utilitarian in terms of
how I thought about people like people
are cogs in a machine we need to build a
machine we need to assemble the cogs in
place put some carrots and sticks and
they will act in accordance with that
and uh Leila with her much more Nuance
understanding of human nature uh was
like that's probably not the best way to
do it and so um I I remember earlier on
I was like I was like how do you how do
you act like you care so much and she
was like I do
care Leila will always prioritize the
human above the role and that's hard to
do as a business owner and so I'll give
you an like a very clear example that
happens all the time in business that's
really tough so let's say someone comes
in and you invest a ton of time in them
like you invest a lot of training a lot
of a lot of real man- hours that you
Mentor you coach the person up and after
6 months of all this investment you
realize that the person is better fit
doing something else not at the company
and not saying like you're firing them
but more like I think you can move on in
doing something bigger or doing
something somewhere else or even doing
something at a competitor's business
because you have an opportunity there l
will genuinely say I really think you
should take it and I am like [__] you
die but
she doesn't think that way Leila really
taught me how to just talk to the human
and really put the human first and when
we do that you get a huge Global benefit
she has been so good at separating role
from Human um that it's benefit us long
term and then also here's the the second
order of magnitude um comeback is that
the person who does get Applause on the
way out and has a I would say like a
graceful exit those people feel like
they owe you one because of how graceful
the exit was and they will send
customers your way they will send they
will often times help you train up the
next person they will help recruit for
you and then long term if they do really
well you might do business together and
we've had every one of those incidents
happen with people that have left our
company and all of those opportunities
and all of those doors would have been
slammed shut if IID put their head on a
spike number 15 do what you are most
afraid of because it's usually the thing
that you need to do most this is like a
classic Leila you know example or
question for strategy is she's like what
are we most afraid of
doing and she'll ask she'll ask the
follow question like what would we do if
we didn't think we could fail and I
think you get really interesting kind of
thought-provoking answers that come from
that especially when you're thinking
about strategic Direction big vision for
where you're trying to go and most times
we realize that we don't take take the
big moves and a lot of times it's cuz
they're painful and that's why we're
afraid of them like there's a hard
conversation like what do what do I what
do I need to do right now there's this
conversation I have to have and so it's
like that's what I'm most afraid of
right now it's usually the thing I need
to do in the Fitness World to give a
completely different parallel usually
the exercises that you hate doing the
most are the ones you usually need to do
right um and so I feel I feel like it's
almost a perfect Coral are in business
is that like a lot of the thing like H I
don't like reading our customer it's
like dude you got to read them every day
even though it's painful you got to read
them right because you got to know how
you can get better and that might be the
thing that you're most TR it's like ah
man I know our stuff's a little outdated
but like H I don't want to like to go
through all the work of like making an
entirely new product or a V2 it's going
to be so it's like what's the thing
we're most afraid of doing it's probably
the thing that you need to do and so
she's again so good at embracing
discomfort and saying like what is
required um that I've just I've learned
that from her and so we've been able to
basically what might have taken me 6
months to confront might take me a week
now to confront and so we just move so
much faster through obstacles because
before I would just put it off so number
16 is that uh networking matters if you
have nothing to offer right don't
sacrifice your goals in order to network
because if you accomplish your goals
this is the big one if you accomplish
your goals you have even more to offer
and the network will be there for you
but the reverse isn't true because if
you don't if you didn't accomplish the
thing in order to network more go to
these events and these these master
minds and these things and and network
and podcast and whatever the less
successful you become the more you
plateau the more irrelevant you become
and the less the doors stay open for you
and the more you have to hustle and
grift and and shake hands and kiss
babies and do all this business card
handout [__] but like the person who
has the best network in the world is
Rogan or Elon or Mr Beast like any of
those people can call whoever they want
up and they don't need to go attend
networking event because here's the
converse of that imagine they had
sacrifi imagine Mr Beast for example or
let's say Elon imagine Elon had
sacrificed the goals that he had for the
business so that he could attend more
networking events and take more meetings
and hey got a second hey can I pick your
brains hey um like hey do hop on this
podcast with me even though it doesn't
really make sense just because someone
asks for your time doesn't mean you owe
it to them just because someone sends
you a message doesn't mean you owe them
a response and this took me a very long
time to learn Lea's been so much better
about that she's so good at saying no
that we practice it I'll even tell you
like we don't really do like New Year's
resolutions or anything like that but
one thing that we committed to this year
was um social obligations or not
obligations if we want to go we will go
and if we don't want to go we will not
go and if they no longer want to be
friends with us that's fine because if
we didn't want to go anyways and they
stop inviting us great Real Talk play it
out well then it's like well they might
say bad things about
us so does everyone else everyone else
you pass have bad things to say about
you it's just part of life number 17 you
cannot be CEO of more than one thing no
matter how much you want to or how good
the opportunity is saying no to
everything means saying yes to the one
thing that matters and so in another
video I basically talk through the
biggest mistakes I made in my life and
one of the recurring themes that
happened before Lila and even as ashamed
as I'm to say this even with Lila um
being with me is that I I would
steamroll her in the earlier parts of
our career before I respected her
opinion as much as I do now um where
she's like don't you feel like we have
enough going on that we shouldn't take
off you know take a take a bite at this
other thing and I'd be like no we got it
we can handle it um and I was wrong and
so I want to be really clear about
something because I think there's a lot
of confusion about this kind of in my
audience I own equity in a lot of
companies that is very different from
being CEO or operator in a lot of
companies at an extreme example if you
buy stock in 10 companies on on the
stock exchange you are an owner of all
those companies you do not operate any
of them ownership is very different from
operating in my opinion you can only
operate one thing very well if you
operate two you operate them at a huge
decrement so I'll give you an example
here if you can run two $1 million
businesses by being CEO of both you have
the potential to run a $10 million
business if you only picked one there's
a Hu it's not one plus one and then it's
really $2 million business it's really
like you have five times the output if
you just focus because the thing is is
all of the wins come from the depth and
the Nuance it comes from the the outsize
Returns come at the very end of the race
that's where you make the smallest
individual improvements but you get the
biggest returns from it and so a simple
example is the difference between gold
medal and silver medal in the Olympics
is a fraction of a second but the
difference between gold and silver in
real life implications is everything
you're either the best in the world or
you're not and who knows who the bronze
medalist was last year no one knows but
everyone knows who us bolt is so there's
huge increment incr there's huge real
life returns for getting this little bit
better that all of the focus centralized
on one thing gets you that you lose out
on because and the thing is is that
because of your own ignorance because
you you're not close enough you can't
see the opportunities that you can't see
they are unknown unknowns from an
opportunity perspective that you only
become aware of if you cut off one of
you know another saying is killing your
babies like you have to kill one of your
babies so that you can let the other one
grow up and so I have been the king of
wanting to keep all my children alive
but the amount of money that I made
after cutting out all of these side
projects and these side hustles and
these gigs and these weird Partnerships
like all of that happened in the first
year of Lea and I being together because
she was like dude I think you could do
so much more if you could actually focus
and like I tell these stories because I
I was that person and so I was like if
you were struggling with this stuff I
get it I'm not like like like I did this
and I [__] up and I'm trying to help
you not [__] up and get there faster I
had a chiropractor agency I had a dental
agency I had my gym launch business
where I was flying around in person
doing launches I still owned my gyms
from back home five of them five of
those are individual businesses I had 1
2 3 had eight businesses that I was CEO
of all of them and it was horrible this
is when I lost everything this is when I
had a DUI head-on collision this is when
my mother went to the hospital also a
terrible thing my grandfather died who I
was really close with all of those
things happened in like a six-month
window and Leila to5 was like what are
you most afraid of right now and I was
like I'm afraid of having this hard
conversation with these partners because
I don't think I should be in these
Partnerships anymore she's like
well they're not going to end themselves
and I'll be really honest with you the
only way that I was really able to do it
was I got in my head on collision in the
DUI and I had a coach who told me um
they're like your stress is going to
kill you just said that like you got out
alive so what are you going to do now
and
so I basically had to face my own death
or morality or just getting out of life
like I had got a head- on collision 60
MPH and I walked away like nothing like
I just walked out of the car and um it
wasn't with another thing it was with an
it was a stopped object everything's
fine um and after that and realizing
that I could have just been dead because
of how stressed I was um I just ripped
the Band-Aid off of everything I like in
a row I did it in one day I just called
the first one up and I was like hey
can't do this anymore like what do you
mean I was like can't do this anymore
not going to do the partnership and the
second piece of advice that I was given
if you have to exit some of these hard
things um was do right by everyone he's
like exit everything and do right by
everyone he's like because if you if you
screw one person over you will regret it
forever and so that means all
stakeholders that meant employees that
meant customers that meant landlords
that meant every Partners everything and
so it was an excruciating process for me
I had to write checks over and over
again to refunds and partners and
buyouts and vendor contracts I had
signed and Lease agreements that I was
on the hook for I mean everything I just
had to it just like it just killed me
but I just had this big thing which was
like the alternative to this is I die
and so I hope that you don't have as
extreme of a circumstance but I only say
this because I understand how hard it
can be and I fortunate or not had a
near-death experience which then made
everything shrink comparison in terms of
how important it seemed to me I had a
business owner friend that I know who
was doing 10 million bucks a year and he
had like 17 businesses and he was
running all of them and it was absolute
Insanity I was like how many business
you he didn't even know he had to pull
up Excel sheet I was like this is
absolute craziness and so I said which
one's the best one he was like this one
I was like okay hypothetical for you I
said if the only thing you had to do in
your life was double this business and
you had no other businesses to care take
care of do you think you could do it
he's like oh my God it' be a [__]
Breeze I'd be able to do that in my
sleep and I was like so why don't
you guy spent the next year getting rid
of all of his extra
companies and that one company has grown
and so the thing is just like we want to
not leave money on the table we want to
take the short-term wins but whenever
you take those you actually take away
from the big pot of gold which is the
main focus that you started to go after
to begin with and so I am am more guilty
of this than just about anyone I can I
don't know of anyone who's been worse
about this than me and so I just say
this because like my income and my net
worth skyrocketed directly proportional
to my ability to say no before I met Lea
I couldn't crack $3 million a year I had
lots of different businesses I had a ton
of stress um and I had a lot of bad
Partnerships not bad Partners mostly bad
structures because I didn't know about
her and when she came in and I watched
how she worked and I watched how she
dealt with people and I watched how she
operated a business I learned so much
and 24 months later I took home $17
million in personal income so I went
from not cracking 3 million in Revenue
to taking home 17 in income that was the
difference that those lessons and
watching her operate taught me and if
all of these stories of all the things
that I learned from Leila have been
helpful I have a separate video where I
break down how I lost over $100 million
in 11 different mistakes that I made in
my life and exactly what you can do to
avoid them and likely you might be
actively making one of those mistakes
right now and I hope you don't so watch
the video